[Music]
well good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
democrats say they despise donald trump
they seem to mean it
they tell us they'll do anything to
prevent him from continuing as president
but if that's really true why are they
working so hard to sabotage their own
chances of replacing him why are
democrats suddenly saying things that
will guarantee
trump's reelection as president in just
the past few months democrats have said
things
that are so out of the mainstream that
it's very hard to imagine voters will
back them
just last night on cnn watch bernie
sanders the front runner
endorse voting for felons who are
currently
behind bars watch this
if somebody commits a serious crime
sexual assault
murder they're going to be punished they
may be in jail for 10 years 20 years 50
years
their whole lives that's what happens
when you commit
a serious crime but i think the right to
vote
is inherent to our democracy yes
even for terrible people
terrible people so how terrible is
sanders talking about
cannibals convicted spies
how about terrorists who kill children
oh yes said bernie sanders they get the
vote too unlike the first
or second amendments that's in the
constitution
senator kim o'hara seem to agree with
that
but people who are in convicted in
prison like the boston marathon bomber
on death row people who are convicted of
sexual assault they should be able to
vote
i think we should have that conversation
okay let's have that conversation
best to do it right now actually because
whenever the left tells you they want a
conversation about something
you can be certain that any dissent on
that subject will be banned a year from
now
by 2020 questioning whether imprisoned
terrorists should vote to earn you a
trip to the hr department
in a lifetime ban from paypal and
twitter so
while we still can consider the story of
dzhokhar tsarnaev sarna first came to
the united states you'll remember on a
tourist visa
with the rest of his family from
kyrgyzstan all of them promptly claimed
asylum here they were given it
over time the tsarnaev collected more
than a hundred thousand dollars
in taxpayer finance government benefits
in 2012 zarna have received u.s
citizenship
and then less than a year later he
murdered three people and maimed
hundreds with a pressure cooker bomb at
the boston marathon now he's on death
row
so democrats hear that story and they
feel outrage it's not that immigrants
repaid our generosity with a terror
attack that may bother you
doesn't bother them the injustice
they're enraged by is that a convicted
terrorist
might not be allowed to help pick our
next president
that's outrageous in their view it's
just the kind of institutionalized
bigotry that
kyrgyzstani refugees like the tsarnaev's
have faced historically in this country
maybe they need reparations too they
definitely need a voice
sort of the convicts of west feliciana
parish louisiana
of the 15 000 people who live in that
parish fully one-third of them are
inmates at the maximum security angola
state prison farm
they are the single largest block of
voters in the area according to bernie
sanders
this is bad because they're being denied
democracy that's racist
once bernie sanders is president they'll
be able to elect the city council and
the sheriff maybe the warden too
that's the kind of progress we're
talking about here